sperrstunde beherbergungs verbot
erweiterte maßen pflicht weniger feiern
das sind die knallharten maßnahmen die
jetzt beschlossen wurden um die
verbreitung des virus einzudämmen
doch jetzt werden immer mehr maßnahmen
von gerichten gekippt oder die länder
setzten sie schlicht nicht mehr um wo
zum beispiel auch die sperrstunde in
berlin ein gericht kippte sie in einem
eilantrag elf bars dürfen jetzt auch
wieder nach 23 uhr geöffnet bleiben das
alkoholverbot bleibt aber bestehen
und bei mir ist niko härting im studio
der anwalt der genau diese elf bars
vertreten hat schön dass sie da sind
herr herr zingler
was war denn ihre kritik an der
sperrstunde und was waren ihre argumente
für diesen eilantrag
wir haben gesagt kroner maßnahmen sind
notwendig aber nur solche maßnahmen die
auch tatsächlich etwas bringen und wir
haben die frage gestellt beim
verwaltungsgericht berlin
was ist denn eigentlich erkenntnisse
gibt dass sich menschen vermehrt nach 23
uhr in gaststätten anstecken und solche
erkenntnisse gibt es schlechterdings
nicht und sie haben ja dann auch recht
bekommen
der eintrag dem wurde stattgegeben was
man jetzt genau die begründung des
gerichts und was bedeutet dieses urteil
vielleicht auch für andere gastronom
hier in berlin
das verwaltungsgericht hat gesagt dass
der welt dass der senat keine nachweise
gebracht hat dass tatsächlich die
gaststätten nach 23 uhr in nennenswertem
maße zum infektionsgeschehen beitragen
und damit fehlt diese fehlt der
sperrstunde schlechterdings die
grundlage der senat hat heute
angekündigt in die beschwerde zu gehen
wir kennen die beschwerde noch nicht das
wird sich zeigen wenn das bestand hat
dann wird dem senat gar nichts anderes
übrig bleiben als die sperrstunde
berlinweit aufzuheben weil die ansonsten
alle gastronomen
dann mit dem gleichen ergebnis zu
gericht gehen können sie habe jetzt
gerade sagt berlinweit aber wäre
natürlich auch noch andere krone
hotspots in deutschland das heißt da
geht dann auch eine sperrstunde wenn die
infektionszahlen dementsprechend hoch
sind könnt ihr dieses urteil auch eine
signalwirkung für ganz deutschland haben
naja die mit der begründung werden sich
auch andere gerichte natürlich
auseinander gesetzt und die frage des
berliner verwaltungsgericht gestellt hat
werden andere gerichte genau so stellen
sie werden von den regierungen der
länder verlangen dass sie einfach eine
begründung liefern warum jetzt
ausgerechnet diese maßnahme das kann ja
nicht einfach so beliebig sein und ich
bezweifle dass in den anderen
bundesländern dort die erkenntnisse
vorhanden sind
da es schlichter schlechterdings solche
erkenntnisse nicht gibt vielen dank herr
herting für ihren besuch im studio und
wir sind sehr gespannt wie das dann
ausgeht vielen dank
danke mehr nachrichten und breaking news
nur bei bet schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren